as
media more media layoffs ring in the New
Year Americans face Prospect of News
desert this is deeply concerning folks
let's see what this is the media
industry is grappling with an alarming
surge in newsroom layoffs during the
holiday season further exacer exac
exacerbated exacerbated great word say
the word exacerbated
exacerbated oh you didn't get I guess I
did Emily you've been writing a lot of
stuff today you
failed ex
exagerated Mark of job Cuts prominent
Outlets such as coni Nest geom media
Vice media and VOX media have recently
downsized their staff contributing to a
48% increase in journalism job Cuts in
2023 compared to previous years the
decline in media jobs is attributed to
the crumbling advertising Revenue model
and the increasing Reliance on
artificial intelligence for Content
creation experts emphasize the urgency
for public and governmental support to
sustain journalism and prevent the
emergence of widespread news desserts
deserts deserts Victor yeah fun fact pbd
deserts have two s's cuz it's so good
deserts One S listen nobody want to live
in the desert you teaching me
English for years I've been trying to do
this for you people are listening to
this you're distracting the out of
it Victor peard a media policy Professor
expects legislative efforts to
strengthen local journalism especially
at the state government level Tom
thoughts on the story first of all it's
the decline in ad revenue and AI is
hurting us we need the government to
help look at the underlying statement
here why is there a decline in ad
Revenue people aren't reading or buying
what you're publishing and so there's
there's less demand for it the other
part of this is is kind of about AI uh
about a week ago Ross levenson who was
the publisher of Sports Illustrated was
relieved of his position position as
part of an acquisition but he was also
relieved of his position because Sports
Illustrated apparently and I know Ross
wherever you are Ross I hope you're
doing well in the next chapter got good
hair though is that the guy yeah I had
no clue I actually I love Ross what a
great hair Ross is a good guy I remember
him from the early mobile Wars in he was
with Fox and he was a good Ally in the
early mobile Wars in uh in Los Angeles
um you know I I I was rather you know as
a colleague I was you know I had a high
opinion of him but something happened
here where they created these AI
generated reporters with fake bios
posted it as the writer of the story and
used AI to write the stories now to me
that sounds like a cost-saving measure
where you're just trying to create now
was creating a a fake reporter how much
a Ross know who know I'm not to debate
that but this is an example where they
were trying to use AI to save money and
write the stories but what happened was
um you know somebody oh my gosh Adam is
suddenly break dancing in the middle of
the studio he's doing a
low had that meaby anyway anyway back to
more those deserts and there's also an
underlying thing here so number one you
know they fire Ross part of you know an
m&a thing and because they say there
were AI reporters that were writing
stories so it wasn't real and it was
deceiving the the subscribers okay fine
but they were trying to save money and
using it but the real issue here why
does AD Revenue decline you don't have
enough people watching it so that you
can charge craft to advertise the
macaroni and cheese that's it it's a
very simple economics craft says you got
a whole bunch of moms on there and kids
to there then I'm going to be
advertising my mac and cheese on you
trust me and if it makes my Mac and
Cheese sell more I'm going to buy even
more ads that's not the problem the
problem is people is places like X where
a huge percent of people said that they
were using X as a news scrape or as a
news in the morning and guess what
people are getting news off social media
off news feeds off independent
newsletters and it's and increasingly
they don't go to their local newspaper
or to their favorite um thing I I enjoy
Business Insider this is not a plug but
it's Business Insider now not Insider
you want to know why because even they
were having a hard time getting
subscribers on Insider so they've laid
off a bunch of people right siiz the
organization they went back and they
called it Business Insider heading for
the niche with a smaller group it's
happening everywhere and there's a whole
lot of it that is due to social media uh
giving the stories immediately and
pretty compelling way so I don't wait
till tomorrow to see it from the LA
Times or Sports Illustrated I think
you're so right that the not the problem
but kind of the problem is the
accessibility I mean I'm 22 and when I
was like deciding my career path in
journalism 01 um my agent who I thought
was crazy at the time shout out to
werman um was like why is your goal to
work on X Network like I was like get me
a local news job then I'll grow up and
up and up and he's like you're starting
your own podcast and I was like are you
crazy no one's going to watch it but I
think the problem quote unquote is that
like I could become just avidly tweeting
on X and I could grow my following and
guess what I have my own audience which
means like then I'll bring in a sponsor
and grab my own Revenue but everyone
could do the same thing and then it's by
by the way I don't know any of those
listed any of those media companies I
probably have never even heard of them
not because I'm ignorant I just that's I
don't know I guess as a gen Z I don't
see that you also have an informed point
of view on Israel and political things
that people would find to be newsworthy
and they would trust it you would be
their news on that topic exactly but I'm
saying they would probably hear it from
me and my podcast and and and my
microphone wherever that may be it's not
going to be like on your traditional
Medias CU now you don't need to
technically watch the news anymore to
find out the news like I'm always on the
go all you guys and nobody's sitting
here home all day you're on X you're on
Instagram you're on maybe you have like
some news app on your phone and it's
likely one channel not like three or
four that you're alternating between so
why would they not go out of business
cuz social media is the future my
agent's been saying it for 5 years and
he's right they're taking over who who's
going to sit home and watch TV all
day anyone guys you guys are worried
about what she did she scare you a
little bit is it I'm SC The Newsroom I
cosign her message she's by the way
here's the other by the way you know a a
if a 52y old heard what she just said
they're so not happy with what she just
said I know by the way I explained to a
lot of old
to they are not happy about this because
she's right and that's the direction
it's going and these teleprompter
gangsters that are up there reading what
somebody else wrote we saw what happened
when there was the strike with writers
strike and actor strike and what Jimmy
Fallon kemel a lot of these guys
couldn't do what they were doing because
the writers Couldn't Write the jokes
like holy I'm not funny anymore
what do I do now right I can't entertain
people anymore the podcast game is a
very different game it's very very hard
very hard to do and some of these guys
going to have to compete in that
Marketplace and it's going to be
catastrophic for many of them filtering
process is here and it's a beautiful
thing and we'll see who's going to
Survive who's not going to survive so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here